[Music]
hurricane isaac has shortened the
republican national convention by a day
shortened it by a day yeah
yeah
the uh
the delegates are relieved because that
means only three days of having to be
fake excited about mitt romney
just like
[Applause]
[Music]
joke by joke i'm reeling you in pal
speaking of florida a former florida
governor jeb bush says it's time for
president obama to stop blaming his
brother for the economy yeah
then when asked why he himself has not
run for president jeb bush said my
brother
the uh
exciting news
let's talk about the mars rover huh
yeah
what the hell was that
it's become a kid show here yeah hey you
want to talk about the mars rover you
bet you do
tomorrow the mars rovers is going to
premiere the new i'm not making this up
is going to premiere the new black-eyed
peas song
by beaming it back to earth
in other words ladies and gentlemen the
rover has turned against us
oh
the machines have risen
i never thought in science fiction it's
never that's they take over and kill us
right right they don't play the black
eyed peas
crazy story over the weekend the world's
oldest person
turned
116.
yeah and she said she lived a long life
because she quote minded her own
business
that's what she said that's true
yeah
in a related story she's also the
world's oldest murder witness
that's such a weird
she saw someone get killed with a musket
probably 116 years ago
i'm not telling anybody
every year on her birthday she's
paranoid what do you want yeah what do
you want to talk about well you're 116.
oh oh yeah right yeah
i didn't see nothing
in new jersey you're going to like this
story
he's like my dad in every way
in new jersey a woman suffers from
persistent genital arousal disorder
which causes her this is real causes her
to have as many as 100 orgasms a day
100 a day
yeah
meanwhile her boyfriend suffers from
persistent high-fiving other dude
syndrome
[Applause]
ah it's my ticket to easy street yeah
i don't gotta do nothing i would totally
not be mentioning the disease i'd be
taking credit yeah
you gotta have the magic touch
doesn't she have a no
in a new interview larry king larry king
said he's not good with gadgets
then he said this interview's over and
hung up his shoe
trouble there
this is kind of weird one of the newest
trends in iraq is knockoffs of american
fast food chains these are real such as
burger friends
that's
and kfg
yeah yeah there's even a cheap knockoff
of an italian restaurant that's called
the olive garden
[Applause]
[Music]
residents of new orleans are bracing for
another possible flood you know that
yeah not because of hurricane isaac but
because they heard snooki's water broke
[Applause]
of course that's true over the weekend
snooki gave birth to a baby boy named
lorenzo
yeah
snooki says the strangest part is that
for the first time she actually knows
the name of the guy sucking her brass i
thought
i thought that was incredible
thank you
[Applause]